je suis malade
quant à la crève et que tu appelles ton
patron pour lui dire que tu viendras pas
un peu obligé d'en faire des tonnes
toi pour bien prouver que tu es malade
je suis malade je peux pour venir
sûrement mourir bon temps c'est normal
tu vas pas faire aux rémois le simple
fait de savoir que je vais pas aller
travailler
rien que ça je me sens un peu déjà mieux
trois minutes après avoir annoncé à ton
patron qu'il n'ira pas travailler
en fait c'est juste la maladie d'aller
travailler avant de consulter un médecin
moi j'ai toujours été un peu ce que j'ai
sur doctissimo mais ça sert à rien ce
genre de site parce que chaque fois
quasiment le conseil du make it réponse
est toujours à bakou reçues le ton
médecin
wtf limite les gens maintenant ils vont
même plus chez le médecin ils font
d'abord confiance un genre de sites mais
tout le monde
mais voilà depuis quelques jours je me
sens pas très bien j'ai mal à la gorge
d'accord donc mal à la gorge
écoutez le meilleur prix et que je peux
vous donner c'est consulter un médecin
ou consultent un médecin le plus
rapidement possible il ya beaucoup de
gens qui se plaignent en disant que les
médecins écrivent mal là parce qu'ils
ont fait de longues études
mais moi perso je préfère un médecin qui
fait mal parce qu'il a fait de longues
études plutôt qu'un médecin décrit comme
anti bio qui que par jour cc aucune chu
antibiotiques
ce que je faisais référence et bien ça
me dérange pas mais j'ai besoin de
prendre ça on a lu ça marche pas sûr
mais je pense c'est marrant parce que le
médecin c'est le seul être vivant que tu
connais pas mais qui tu fais totalement
confiance
toi tu fais tout ce qui dit fête à aller
maintenant tous efforts or maintenant
continuer en obtenant ce centre ah ah
ah d'accord maintenant mettez vous en
slip en faisant la brebis
ah c'est bon j'ai trouvé ce que vous
avez vous êtes complètement con non
médecins il est un peu celle où il parle
en baragouinant pendant qu'il est
vraiment sous les quoi genre en avant
qu'il y en a marre de répéter la même
chose à chaque fois à chaque
consultation en amont et aval au fond de
la gorge de mon avis tu peux rajouter le
temps de voir par jour je ne les prends
des fois je me demande si parle toujours
comme ça dans sa vie
j'ai j'ai très très vite et fermement
c'est ça tout ce que leurs distractions
à mon âge je soigne avec 3 km par jour
entre les repas plus sur nos épaules un
petit arrêt maladie au chapitre on a
bien fait
cette page et de master b j'aurais trop
voulu être médecin ou du japon en fait
comme le mec deux kops sept médecins ça
va être génial
dès que tu es un problème t'as pas
besoin d'aller voir le médecin tu peux
tout te soigner oh non j'ai une
bronchite mix'n laryngite
bon bah de comprimés que la bauxite par
jour puissant doliprane ça me ferait 42
euros c'est un peu cher
moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'être médecin
juste pour au moins une fois dans ma vie
pouvoir faire ça mais c'est moi je mets
ta montre je déconne c'est toujours aimé
dire ça un jour bonne journée
ces styles et les métiers comme ça où tu
peux intervenir en cas d'urgence comme
un héros il ya plein de métiers ou en
cas d'urgence tout ça vraiment à rien je
suis boulanger moi ça m'est arrivé une
fois d'aller aux urgences pour une
urgence mais en voyant un maximum
d'hémoglobine là bas j'ai compris que
mon urgence en fait était quand même
moins urgente que d'autres urgences si
ça me dérange pas ça peut vous êtes 4
millions avoir rejoint la page facebook
c'est énormissime merci à tous c'est
vraiment cool ça me fait trop plaisir
dsit pas rejoindre ma page tout simple
peut-être on sera 4 millions 1
je sais pas ce que tu as mais si je peux
donner un petit conseil savoir médecin
je joue mon spectacle norman sur scène
dans les zénith de france à partir
d'avril prochain
je joue à amiens à rouen à châlons en
champagne à metz fin je crois et dans
pleins pleins d'autres villes alors
venez me voir en spectacle suis vraiment
hyper marrant c'est c'est abusé un
préservatif un préservatif
je sais pas peut-être tu attends je
vérifie j'en ai 16 et un max de
lubrifiants nickel